the Food and Drug Administration is
ordering a Las Vegas company to recall
all of its dietary supplements
containing the ingredient kratom it is
linked to a nationwide salmonella
outbreak the FDA says this is its first
mandatory recall for a tainted food
product the agency says 26 items with
kratom from four companies including the
one from Las Vegas tested positive for
salmonella
there are nearly 90 reported infections
in 35 states and a war nurse here with
the concerns over kratom and a good
morning good morning well some consumers
argue that kratom can be an alternative
pain medicine or a treatment for opioid
withdrawal but the FDA says kratom has
not been proven safe and effective and
the salmonella outbreak is adding to
existing concerns over loosely regulated
dietary supplements when I first started
reading about it it sounded like snake
oil to me Andrew Turner is a military
veteran who turned to kratom three years
ago to help with pain from service
injuries and PTSD pharmaceutical
solutions were not working in my
situation and I was steadily
deteriorating Turner uses kratom powder
to make tea he buys it online from a
company he says follows the strictest
manufacturing and testing standards and
shares those test results with customers
since early March three companies that
sell kratom products have issued
voluntary recalls that the FDA's request
due to salmonella contamination but on
Tuesday the agency issued its first
mandatory recall order for all of
triangle Pharma naturals LLC's food
products containing kratom FDA
Commissioner Scott Gottlieb said in a
statement this action is based on the
imminent health risk posed by the
contamination of this product with
Salmonella and the refusal of this
company to voluntarily act we commend
the FDA for taking swift action to
protect the public Chuck Bell is the
program's director for consumers Union
the policy division of Consumer Reports
he says dietary supplements like kratom
run the risk of containing contaminated
ingredients the issue is that they're
not subject to pre market safety testing
so unlike prescription drugs they've not
been shown to be either safe or
effective but Turner says he were
tougher regulations on kratom may cut
off access people should be able to make
a decision for themselves and weigh the
risks versus the benefits look at the
research that's available out there the
FDA is advising consumers to avoid
kratom and kratom containing products
the agency says it will continue working
with the Centers for Disease Control to
investigate the ongoing outbreak
triangle Pharma Naturals did not respond
to our request for comments we were
unable to reach them but there's a lot
of kratom fans out there too who swear
by it they don't want it off the market
interesting that the FDA's first
mandatory recalls yeah it is thank you
very much Anna